this right here is a picture of
Henrietta and Ari Etta Swan Leavitt and
she made a little over a hundred years
ago this is in the early 1900s while
working for Edward Charles Pickering who
was a Harvard astronomer while working
for his observatory she made what is
arguably well definitely one of the most
important discoveries in all of
astronomy and probably and you know I
would say it ranks their top three
because it really enabled people like
Hubble to start realizing that the
universe is expanding or even being able
to think about how to measure distances
to objects in space well beyond the
reach of our tools with parallax we saw
with parallax you have to be have
extremely sensitive instruments just to
even measure distances to stars
relatively close to us very sensitive
instruments to get to stars maybe
further out into our galaxy and you we
don't have the instruments even today to
measure things beyond our galaxy but
because of Henrietta Swan Leavitt we can
we were able to approximate her or get
good census of the distance to objects
beyond our galaxy so let's just think
about what she did so her job was
literally to classify stars in the Large
Magellanic I have trouble saying that
Magellanic Club Magellanic Cloud and the
small Majella Magellanic Clouds and this
is what they look like from the southern
hemisphere this is the large right over
here and that this is the small right
over here and remember this is before
this is before Hubble realize that there
or showed the the world that there are
stars beyond our Gaucher that there are
galaxies beyond our galaxy so at this
point in time people didn't even fully
appreciate that these were separate
galaxies we just said hey these are kind
of these blobs or these clusters of
stars that we see in the southern
hemisphere and just to get a sense of
where they are relative to our galaxy
the Milky Way galaxy this is obviously
not an actual picture we can't take a
picture from this vantage point this
would have to be very very far away but
this is the Milky Way right here and
this is the small Magellanic Cloud and
this is the Large Magellanic Cloud
getting better
saying it so her job was literally just
to classify just to classify the the the
different stars that she saw but while
she was classifying she looked at these
things called variables it turns out
what she was looking at where class of
stars called Cepheid or c fiood c fiood
variable c fiood variable stars and
what's interesting about them is two
things they're SuperDuper bright they're
up to 30,000 times as luminous as their
son and they're 5 to 20 times more
massive than the Sun five to twenty
times the sun's mass but what makes them
interesting is one they're really bright
so you can see them from really far away
you can see these C fiood variable stars
in other galaxies in fact we can see it
well beyond even the small Magellanic
Cloud or the Large Magellanic Cloud but
you can see these stars and other
galaxies and what's even more
interesting about them is that they're
their intensity is variable that they
become brighter and dimmer with with a
well-defined period so if you're looking
at a Cepheid variable star and this is
just kind of a simulation a very cheap
simulation it might look like this and
then over the course of the next 3-4
days it might reduce an intensity to
something like this and then after 3 4
days again it will look like this and
then it will look like this again so
it's in its actual intensity is going up
and down with the well-defined period so
if this takes three days and this is
another three days then the period one
entire cycle of it's going from low
intensity back to high intensity is
going to be 6 days so this is a 6 day
period and what Henrietta what Henrietta
Leavitt saw and this wasn't an obvious
thing to do she plotted she assumed she
assumed that things everything in each
of these clouds are roughly the same
distance away everything the large
Mountain Magellanic Cloud is roughly the
same distance way and it you know it's
obviously not exact this is an entire
galaxy so you have obviously things
further away in that galaxy and things
closer up you have stars here and here
and their distance is going to be
exactly the same to us that we're
sitting maybe over here someplace but
it's going to be close it wasn't a bad
approximation and
I'm making that assumption she saw
something pretty neat if she plotted so
let me plot this right over here so she
plotted on the horizontal axis is she
applauded the relative relative
luminosity so really the only way that
she could measure this is just how did
they how bright did they look to her and
she's assuming that they're same
distance so obviously if you have a
brighter star but it's much much further
away it's going to look dimmer so if you
assume that they're all the same roughly
the same distance then how bright it is
will tell you how how bright it is at
the actual star so she prodded she
plotted relative luminosity of a star on
one axis and on the other axis she
plotted she prodded the period of these
variable stars she plotted the period
and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do
this on a logarithmic scale so let's say
that this is in days so this is one day
this is 10 days this is 100 days right
over here it's a logarithmic scale
because I'm going up in powers of 10 I
could say that if we say these are if we
take the log of these this would be 0
this would be 1 this would be 2 and so
that's what I'm using as a scale so I'm
using the log of the period or I'm just
marking them as 1 10 100 but I'm giving
each of these factors of 10 and equal
spacing but when you plot it on this
scale the relative luminosity versus the
period she got a plot that looks
something like this and this is
obviously not exact
she got a plot that looks something like
this it was a fairly linear relationship
when you plot the relative luminosity
against the log of the period so this is
obviously a logarithmic scale over here
and so you could fit a line and why this
is why I'd argue and I think most people
would argue this is one of the most
important discoveries in astronomy is if
you know because think about what the
problem here is we can look at all of
these stars in space we can look at
let's say you look at a fraction of the
sky and you look at something that looks
like that so it's really bright and then
you see something dim that looks like
that so if you're a very superficial
understand you say oh this this star
is brighter you say that this is a
fundamentally brighter star but how do
you know that maybe maybe instead of
being brighter maybe it's just a dimmer
closer star maybe this is a closer storm
maybe this is an entire galaxy but it's
so far away that you can't even tell but
all of a sudden with you if you buy by
the work that that that Henrietta
Leavitt did if you know if you see one
of these Cepheid variable stars in
another galaxy you know it's relative
brightness compared to other Cepheid
variable stars and so if you can place
just one of these Cepheid variable stars
if you know exactly the distance to one
of them and then you know it's absolute
luminosity you then know the absolute
value manasa t of any other Cepheid
variable stars so let's say that let's
say using parallax let's say using
parallax which is our other tool we find
let's say there's some star in our
galaxy and let's say using parallax
using parallax we're able to come up
with a pretty good measure that it is I
don't know let's say it's a hundred
light years away
light-years and this star is a Cepheid
this is a this is a Cepheid variable
star and let's say it's period let's say
its period is one day it's one day so we
know we now know something interesting
we know we know variable stars with a
period of one day at a hundred light
years away will look like this will look
like this drawing right over here so if
we later on if we later on see if we
later on see a Cepheid variable star
with a with a with a period of one day
so it goes gets brighter and dim over
the course of one day and maybe it's red
shifted as well but maybe it looks a
little bit dimmer it looks like this we
now know we now know that it had that if
it was a hundred light years away it
would have this luminosity so based on
how much dimmer it is we can then figure
out how much further away this Cepheid
variable star is and that confuses a
little bit I'll do a little bit more
details in the next few videos so we can
get a closer sense of how the math would
work but this was a big discovery just
discovering this class of stars this Fe
variable class she wasn't the one who
discovered them people knew before her
that there were these stars that got
brighter and dimmer but what her big
discovery was is seeing this linear
relationship between the relative
luminosity of these stars and their
period because then if we see Cepheid
variable stars in completely different
galaxies or galactic clusters by looking
at the period we know what their real
relative luminosity is and then we could
guess how far those things really are or
not we could estimate how far those
things really are